you've talked about the Muslim world
being in war with the West
what is the Trump plan long term to try
to make the relationship between the
Muslim world and the Western world
better the first thing you have to do is
get them to respect the West and respect
us and if they're not going to respect
us it's never going to work
so one element would be have people in
Flajnik world respect the West I don't
any other I don't think we can do
anything and I don't think you're going
to be successful unless they respect you
and they have no respect for a president
and they have no respect for our country
right now as you were asked about
whether you would rule out using
tactical nuclear weapons against Isis
you rule that out or is that something
you'd caught them I think I'd probably
be very very late compared to my
opponents that are running so you would
you would rule in the possibility of
using nuclear weapons against Isis well
I'm never going to rule anything out
right and I wouldn't want to say even if
I felt it wasn't going I wouldn't want
to tell you that because at a minimum I
want them to think maybe we would use it
okay it's the worst thing when we do
these interviews with everybody not me
and you ask a question like that and
everybody comes clean and they're so
honest you know we need unpredictability
the enemy we have enemies Isis is a
enemy and it's an enemy not wearing
uniform so we don't even know who the
enemy is
the fact is we need unpredictability and
when you ask a question like that it's a
very it's a very sad thing to have to
answer it because the enemy is watching
and I have a very good chance of winning
and I frankly don't want the enemy to
know how I'm thinking understood but
with that being said I don't rule out
anything I would say definitely nuclear
weapons are a last resort there are
people who say that America needs to be
the leader of NATO that that's an
important role do you agree America
should be paying a very disproportionate
share we're paying for a lot of NATO and
it's helping them more than it's helping
us so we're the ones always fighting
we're the ones putting up a lot of the
money for NATO disproportionately a lot
right now we put up a lot of the money
for a lot of countries you know we
defend South Korea we defend Saudi
Arabia we defend Japan we defend Germany
but we put up a lot of money and then
people wonder I wonder why we own 19
trillion dollars
so should America be the leader of NATO
or not I said I think NATO may be
obsolete Eneida was set up a long time
ago many many years ago when things were
different things are different now we
were a rich nation then we had nothing
but money we have nothing but power and
and you know far more than we have today
in a true sense and I think NATO you
have to really examine NATO and it
doesn't really help us it's helping
other countries and I don't think those
other countries appreciate what we're
doing so just to be clear you made two
slightly different arguments there I
just want to clarify one of them is that
the u.s. that you might want to see the
u.s. pay less money into NATO because
that one definitely that's definitely
wonderful but it's possible that NATO is
obsolete it's classified should because
possible I would certainly look at it